need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something greater
inside you as well
you've got Michael Jordan level talent
add something so get ready for some
comfort breaking ideas from Kristen
Stewart in my take on her top ten roses
success to give you the belief that you
need
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one take risks you're asking like why
people want to make act in movies I
totally just wanted to be a part of it I
just wanted to go to work I wanted to
have a job and the only job that you can
have as a kid on his dad's be an actor
and so when I first sarted I was like
very much of the mind that it was like
I'm just a member of the crew like you
know don't get it twisted I am a
professional liar and blah blah blah and
then I started getting older and I was
like no no I just developed this
reverence because of what it was give
feeding me and there was this huge
distinction between people that think
they know everything and there are
technicians that really do and and the
ones that truly create like honestly are
the technicians that are truly artists
know nothing and it's terrifying and
it's still worth it and it's like the
coolest thing ever like I would never do
anything if I like knew how it was gonna
end up yeah um there's like when I say
they know nothing you mean they're
willing to give up yeah their knowledge
in order to get something you've never
made this movie before so you actually
don't know how to do it you know what I
mean you have like experience and you
have dedication based on some feeling
you had but um you know any time you
think you know like how to do something
that's definitely not it's not what I'm
into you can't do stuff unless there's
like massive risk involved or else it's
just like now I'm creating a product in
order to be like deemed successful and
that's cool but it's not fun rule number
two be genuine I remember from the
movies to this that is so easy to be
seduced by the money on the glamour and
everything in Hollywood and to but to
keep true to who you really are it's
guess that's kind of a challenge
sometimes when you know when you you're
just a part of something that seem a
little fake I don't know how is how are
you keeping so weak because you look so
real you just act like you're like a
normal girl or you know I don't know
what I would be doing if I hadn't
started acting so young and then just
had that like kind of inform my
lifestyle and like what I like to do how
I just about my time like what I like to
focus on like my art and if that's what
you're focused on like that's just it's
it's genuine it's pure
usually it's just so obvious when people
want to be like fresh and famous and
like win the popularity contest and they
also like have fun acting too but it's
like not the same thing like it's just
not that's not why I do stuff but did
you want that part in the beginning you
know when I'm 9 ya know it was like no
I'm genuinely no yeah rule number three
don't over prepare Kristen just comes on
the set you know when he just takes the
script you know go through it a little
bit and then she knows everything and
she's present how annoying it's just
like that I'm addicted to the first time
I'm addicted to that feeling that you've
not constructed something but that
you're really truly discovering
something and you know it's like there's
something happens for me once and then
everything after feels like a false
imitation so I don't like to read stuff
too much beforehand because I want to I
want to barely barely barely know the
words so I'm like searching for them
rule number four leave your comfort zone
when I do stuff that really scares me
good things happen you know I always
feel like good stuff happens like really
fast aren't really terrified and you
know it's uh yeah I think that's for
most of us I think most of us if you
push yourself past a comfort level and a
comfort zone you you find out things
about yourself that you wouldn't have
found out a hundred percent yeah also if
you want to learn from other successful
women entrepreneurs checking my 2:54
girl boss series it's free the link to
join is in the description below become
so skilled so vigilant so flat
out fantastic at what you do that your
talent cannot be dismissed there's a lot
of man's world out there but
entrepreneurship is a level playing
field there's no rules it's important
for us to remember the joy in what we do
it's important to be effective in our
workplace but it's important to
cultivate the moments that just bring us
joy rule number five be obsessed I'm so
not like a performer I would never you
know like going on TV I'm always like
yeah I you know my the drive to do it is
so different to other people and I'm not
discrediting that there-there are born
performers there are people that you
love to watch just be themselves and I
like to be a little bit more in control
I like to I like to make something and I
mean I've grown up in the business my
parents do it there aren't there crew
and I've really just loved the movies my
whole life I've totally and completely
glorified I think they're really
important I think you can do so much
personally and for other people like
even if nobody saw snow white the
experience of it has given me so much
and I think I think I want to do that
forever
I want to making these I'm like obsessed
with it rule number six find your
passion you come from a filmmaking
family they've always been had the
thought that you have an orientation to
filmmaking that is a little bit
different from a lot of your fellow
actors I wanted to know where my parents
were for 18 hours and and and it was
always like you know exciting and and
they always came back like tired but
like it was so it was so worth sleeping
six hours and getting up to do it again
and they had weird stuff in their
pockets and they smelled like they'd
been a thousand places and I was like
what happened you your jacket is
freezing it's not even cold here like I
yeah so I I love the idea that there's
all these people protecting something
really precious and hard to define and
the only way to define it is to get to
the end of this thing rule number seven
know your strengths and weaknesses
rule number eight follow your gut you
have like six movies coming out this
year I think right six this year is that
what I read yeah something like that Wow
and they're all kind of smaller more
independent movies that you've chosen to
kind of go to smaller films why is that
just for the for the script itself I've
always been really liked the least
tactful person and so ya know I've been
rarely let down by following my gut and
sort of being drawn to creative
endeavors that just feel right without
an explanation and they've been small
and big like you know this movie that
we're talking about now or whatever
around it was huge it's like a huge
Angley picture and yeah so I'm just kind
of all over the map you said that you
you know you like it when you just meet
somebody and you click with them yeah
I've really rarely been wrong about
those feelings like I I always like come
crashing down if I meet somebody like
Hawaii like and and we don't love each
other I'm like wait wait wait wait wait
you tricked me you're a crazy person
you're a sociopath and those exist but
it's rare and so like I've really grown
to trust that feeling it's always been
really fruitful rule number nine don't
focus on the money I would never
draw attention to the distinction
between doing a big movie in a small and
because then you're like cool well why
are you doing it that's weird
and I've always like I mean I guess you
could technically draw distinctions
because you have more money to play with
and then like it kind of I mean
naturally affects the dynamic a little
bit but like at the end of the day when
you're really yeah I've never approached
anything going oh this is bigger now
therefore I'm like less entitled to
something meaningful or something that's
every what's what you think and rule
number 10 the last one before very
special bonus clip is take action on
your ideas it's funny because Jodie
Foster told me I was I was helping honor
her at this ceremony I introduced her at
her I can't remember if it was like a
star on the Walk of Fame or if it was
like I don't think was a handprint she's
it was this it was she got a star on the
Walk of Fame and I introduced her and it
was the first time I'd seen her in a
really long time you did panic room
together yeah and so I she was like what
are you up to what you doing and I told
her I was making the short film and she
was like finally like I I was surprised
and knowing you and you were a little
I'm surprised that you kept acting as
much as you did cuz you seem like
somebody who wants to make something and
do it yourself and I was like yeah I'm
actually just now starting to do that
I'm gonna make a short film and she was
like cool like the first thing you're
gonna realize or the first thing they're
gonna learn is that you already know and
like you just need to start doing it now
I've got a special bonus clip on how to
be free that I think you're gonna enjoy
but before that is time for the three
point landing questions let's go from
just watching the video to taking action
here we go question number one what idea
of yours do you need to take some action
on number two what big decision is your
gut telling you to follow right now and
number three how will you be obsessed in
the next week about making that big
change happen and if you're gonna take
some immediate action after watching
this video give me a hash tag believe
down in the comments as well I'm
definitely like opened up as I've gotten
a little older and being super famous
like I just found insane but uh
I've kind of started like breaking down
these walls that I built for myself
because I noticed that I actually as
much as people couldn't see me I also
couldn't see over them and so I was like
stuck in this sort of isolated spot and
so I'm like really like allowing myself
to be like much more productively like a
part of like social life as normal
people are so I think if I was just
completely not famous for a day I would
like to stay outside all day and like
let my face hang out and like stare in
people and be like hey what's up
if you want to see the top 10 I did on
Emma Stone check out the video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there there are sacrifices in any
relationship their sacrifices every job
requires compromise in different
circumstances you need to do things that
you don't necessarily want to do